c'est un musée en plein air cette ville
de Saint-Germain boucle de scène vous
invite à suivre leurs nouveaux chemins
impressionnistes de petites randonnées
de 2 à 5 km balisé de reproduction
d'œuvres placé là où les artistes ont
posé leur chevalet en fait il y a plus
de 200 uvres qui ont été peintes à
Saint-Germain boucle de scèes que ce
soit Saint-Germain en laè Chatou
croissie le port marli et et j'en oublie
donc on n pas pu toutes les avoir il
fallait d'abord qu'il y ait une bonne
définition il fallait qu'il y ait une
cohérence on voulait que ça ça crée un
parcours intéressant avec des sujets
aussi différents certains vont vont
évoquer les loisirs d'autres vont
évoquer l'industrialisation enfin les
sujets sont différents et on voulait
justement sensibiliser à l'époque c'est
vraiment un moyen de découvrir l'époque
de fin 19e début début 20e en longeant
la scène le parcours du port Marley est
le plus petit mais le plus dense avec 12
tableaux une ville qu'afred siisley
affectionne il il a peint de nombreuses
toiles sur cette commune comme en
1876 où la crue de la scène lui offre un
sujet de travail sur un motif qu'il
chérit tant l'eau et ses reflets ce sont
pas les premiers à être sensibles à la
beauté des lieux je pense tout d'abord à
des rois ce qui était le privilège un
privilège royal l'apanage des des des
grandes semondes va se démocratiser au
19e siècle et ce sont nos peintres
impressionnistes et bien qui vont
vouloir immortaliser ces paysages
véritable terre de l'impression
de l'ancienne forge du centre-ville
jusqu'à l'abevoir de Marl Leroi sur
chaque parcours différents sujets sont
abordés certains vont évoquer les
loisirs de la société de l'époque alors
que d'autres vont montrer
l'industrialisation des lieux un témoin
de l'histoire de la fin du 19e début 20e
siècle donc à Saint-Germain boucle de
scène l'idée c'est effectivement que que
les habitants découvrent pour ceux qui
connaissent pas bah tous les tableaux
qui ont été peints ici par une quinzaine
d'artistes et c'est aussi de les à se
balader tout simplement pour compléter
la visite l'Office de Tourisme propose
pour chaque œuvre des activités à faire
dans les environs à l'heure actuelle
cette parcours sont disponibles de
randonnées supplémentaires ouvriront au
printemps 2024 à Louvre sienne et
Saint-Germain en lait